you've just seen the governor's award
later this evening the governor's ball
will be held just one of many balls
being held all over Hollywood tonight
there are five extraordinary actresses
in our next category and I've been
honored to to be asked to present this
award here are the nominees for Best
Performance by an actress in a
supporting role Penelope Cruz in nine
[Applause]
Bharath Amiga in up in the air Maggie
Gyllenhaal in crazy heart Anna Kendrick
in up in the air Monique in precious
based on the novel push by Sapphire
and the winner is Monique empresas based
on the novel push by Sapphire
[Applause]
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for money
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
first I would like to thank the Academy
for showing that it can be about the
performance and not the politics
I want to thank miss Hattie McDaniel for
enduring all that she had to so that I
would not have to Tyler Perry and Oprah
Winfrey because you touched it the whole
world saw it
Ricky Anderson our Attorney of Anderson
and Smith thank you for your hard work
my entire beatsie family my precious
family thank you so much to my amazing
husband Sidney thank you for showing me
that sometimes you have to forego doing
what's popular in order to do what's
right and baby you were so right god
bless us all
you